we're on yeah okay here we are again I'm
frustrating it's awful dark it lightened
up it just takes a second to do I don't
know how it looks like for people that
are watching it but for us it's like
target and the light comes on see what's
going on here but yeah so yeah we
decided we were gonna do another little
livestream they probably won't be as
long as yesterday because this is just
gonna be a movie review not a sidetrack
so hopefully we don't go off on too many
tangents but I wanted to do review this
one because this one just dropped on
shutter probably like hey bee's nest
movies and hey Thomas Carlisle because
this one just dropped on shutter like
yesterday or the day before and I
noticed that there was hardly any
reviews of it anywhere so this must be
very very very new this is a 2020 movie
called the bone box now this is a movie
that is apparently from what I could
discern this is the directorial debut of
a guy named Luke Denton or I guess
that's how you pronounce it I think he
was a co-writer on a movie called snow
falls before but which I haven't seen hi
Beth hi mango badger I can't see it's
probably there's probably like a lag
yeah I would imagine and hello Sondra or
Sandra still here to see the duct tape
yeah so this just dropped it's I'm gonna
call this a it's kind of like a ghost
story but it's also kind of like a
psychological horror so the basic
premise of this is that there's this guy
named Tom and as kind of as it goes on
you find out that his wife has died of
cancer I believe was like a year before
and he has moved in with his aunt
Florence who incidentally is played by
Maria Olson who played one of the really
weird looking like castigates casting
agents in starry eyes which is also a
really good movie if you want to check
that one out I think 1816 2017 no movies
older than that 2014 ah but yes she was
in that so he moves in with his aunt
Florence after her husband dies so his
uncle has died and she's kind of gonna
move out and she's quite wealthy so tom
is gonna help her
like pack up the house and you know
everything like that and hopefully I
guess cuz he's kind of at a loss in his
life and they're kind of bonding and he
needs a play day and she has a lot of
money so she like gets him some help
now it also turns out that before Tom's
wife died and I guess her cancer
treatment was really expensive so he
kind of got into gambling debt like a
really bad gambling debt like because he
was trying to make money to like pay for
her cancer treatment so what he has
decided to do is that his aunt Florence
lives in you know kind of creepy old
mansion or whatever like right next to
or honestly it looks like it's on the
same grounds it's like this really big
Cemetery so he's decided that he's gonna
look into grave robbing like you do
because he has this friend who's
actually played by a woman that was in
the invitation I think the his the whole
time I was like man that actress is so
familiar where ever I seen her and that
I loved her up her name is Michele crew
siak I think but yeah she was in the
invitation so her this is kind of a
small town I guess they don't really
show much of the town or anything like
that pretty much the whole movie like
takes place other than an opening scene
like in the graveyard pretty much the
whole movie takes place like inside this
house so it's like very claustrophobic
which I think kind of worked to its
advantage but she is um so so this woman
is like you know she's got her own
issues too but her dad is like the
Undertaker of the town Undertaker so she
knows like all the all the skinny about
like who died and who got buried with
what and if there's any like valuable
[ __ ] and like some people's coffins and
stuff like that so she passes on this
information to Tom in the hopes that
she'll kind of get a cut of it too now
they don't come across as like horrible
people or anything like that they just
come across as very desperate people who
are resorting to desperate situations so
at the very beginning of the movie you
see Tom and he's like running through
the brave' yard and he's got like this
box and it's got what kind of all these
valuables and it like he's jewelry and
you know various trinkets and things
like that
that he is planning to pawn to get some
money to pay back his creditors because
I think he owes like $20,000 in gambling
debt or something like that but as time
goes on he starts seeing things around
the house which lead
to believe that the the dead people
whose things he took are like stocking
him one of whom is his uncle because he
also takes ship from his uncle's grave
which his aunt doesn't know so there's
all this [ __ ] going on now it's funny
because I think when we remember we were
doing the Illuminati show I think this
is when we were talking about this but I
think we were talking about a haunting
and even like a lot of horror movies and
stuff like that where it's always kind
of like the woman that sees the ghosts
and like the dude doesn't believe her
and I was like man is there another is
there a movie where the reverse is true
this is one this is the one where the
dude is the only one who sees the ghosts
no one else sees them no one else hears
anything so there's so there's kind of
like an ambiguity whether he's really in
whether whether the house is really
haunted whether these people are ghosts
and have come to like get him or whether
like all of the trauma that he's gone
through his life and his guilt about
stealing from the dead people and
everything like that is just like
causing him to see things now I will say
that like I said this a very low-budget
movie it's pretty much one location you
know the opening scene is just him
running through the graveyard like after
he's stolen all this stuff and after
that I'm pretty sure I remember the old
the whole thing is shot either inside
the house or just right outside the
house like on the steps but like I said
I think that's good because that gives
it kind of like a real claustrophobia to
now this does not have any CGI it
doesn't really have a lot of gore and
you can know jump scares that I can
remember anything like that it's just
like a really it reminded me a little
bit like the vibe of it and stuff it
kind of reminded me of a little bit of
like the changeling or something like
that where it's like there's not a lot
of real overt [ __ ] but the [ __ ] you see
is like kind of unsettling but the
ghosts like don't look like they're not
CGI or nothing they've pretty much just
look like real people but they just kind
of build up this whole thing where it's
like you know like a little bicycle bell
or like you know him seeing somebody or
like a painting with like a figure that
was like moving closer to the house and
things like that so it's just like all
these little kind of things that build
up and like I said it's more like a
psychological thing because you're not
really sure if he's
the only one seeing these ghosts because
they don't exist and because they're
just like you know a figment of his
imagination or if the house is actually
haunted and it just seems to be that
he's the only one that can see them you
know what I mean yeah from my point of
view and I'm sure everybody [ __ ]
watching the stream knows that I didn't
like in the first two or three minutes
but to me this is another one that I put
in the bin of it would have made a
better play than a movie I kind of like
a lot of visuality in movies well yeah
this one is a very it is no I was
thinking that too because a lot of it
has to do with because there's not a
huge amount of characters a lot of it
has to do with the interactions of the
characters because there's like long
scenes with like you know conversations
between the characters and then talking
about things and then it'll kind of be
broken up with like him wandering or a
house around the house and like seeing
somebody and you know ever no one else
can see them you know what I mean like
seeing kind of creepy imagery seemed
like a little boy seeing a bride seeing
other things and um you know but they're
not ghostly in any way so you know how
you approach the movie like I said it
seems like this is getting real like
some people either really really dug it
you know saying it's kind of like a
throwback like an old school just kind
of a slow burn haunted house type movie
with with no jump scares no anything
like that just kind of like creepy
imagery and just like a creepy story and
then like other people saying like what
you said it's like you know it's not
like super action-packed it's not you
know it's it's very conversation based
very character-based you know it goes a
lot into you know the psychology of the
main character and like the interactions
between the characters and stuff like
that so it was to me it was just more
like theatre than it was yeah film you
know I mean cinema has to be visual for
me that's just my that's my tastes yeah
you know
and this just wasn't very visual yeah it
wasn't in a lot of ways I'm amazed it is
very it was very dialogue heavy like I
said not I don't not in the same way
that say confessional was which we
reviewed like last week or whatever that
very much seemed like a play you know
what I mean this one you know like I
said they moved around the house like
other
happened you know there was like a fight
with the with the you know guy that he
owed money to and stuff like that so
like [ __ ] did happen so it wasn't just
people talking to the camera the whole
time so it wasn't that experimental but
I can see how if you're not really into
just these real low-key
you know dialogue heavy like ghost story
type things or psychological type horror
movies then probably you will be bored
with it I mean I found it really
interesting but I can I can see that a
pro like I'm not gonna [ __ ] on people
for feeling like that because I can see
how you would feel like that but I found
it really interesting yeah I'd get into
it no sudden I start just looking at my
damn tablet and going yeah okay just you
know just like I said it's just it was
not a visual experience to me and that's
just you know I mean dude that's for me
that's what cinema is with the submit a
decent play probably yeah because you
know when it's on stage you know there's
not gonna be any special effects to
speak of they can't show you much so the
the actress have to [ __ ] put on a
performance to draw you in and it's
gonna be psychological and dialogue
that's all you have when you're on stage
yeah but that's wasted with cinema
that's why I didn't like it yeah
which you know like I said I can
understand that yeah um I didn't really
like I liked the idea of this though I
mean I really liked the concept behind
it and I've seen it compared to the
changeling and it's kind of similar in
the sense even though the changeling had
a lot more locations and things like
that that you know whereas this one was
very confined to like one household but
this also reminded me a little bit you
remember um I don't remember if they did
a haunting episode or maybe it was
paranormal witness the Dybbuk box yeah
you know what I mean it kind of invited
me like a little bit of that but I mean
it is a thing I mean I think I'm you
know I'm not an undertaker obviously but
I think it is a thing where they have
like and I think that is what it's
called it's called the bone box that has
like all the the effects of the dead
people like in it and that's what he
stole even it had like more than one
person's because that was kind of the
whole thing like you know that was had
to do with like all the manifestations
that he was supposedly seeing you know
it was like three or four different
people whose stuff that he had taken
like from their graves
so but I really really liked that idea
of like these kind of like remnants
coming after him but you don't really
know if if they're really there because
he's the only one that sees them so like
I said I like to that they subvert 'add
the woman is the only one that sees [ __ ]
troop yeah and men like made it opposite
where he was the only one seeing them
and his friend it wasn't his girlfriend
it was just like a female friend that he
had um you know that happened to be like
The Undertaker's daughter she was the
one that was giving him the files and
the information or everything and she's
just like not buying it she's like no
man that's just in your imagination I
don't see anything you know nothing's
here and she's not hearing anything so I
kind of liked that they subvert in that
troop and it's just funny that I brought
it up the other day it was like that I
couldn't think of a movie that it's
averted that and I was like here I was
very happy to see that we also you know
while we were kind of on the topic since
we're live might as well I think shudder
also added last night's they usually add
like two or three at a time they also
added the 1983 movie mausoleum
yeah which I don't think I ever saw not
bad I like to banter it's very cheesy
yeah I like it better than this when it
did have a lot more of a visual stimulus
to it you know I mean it wasn't was the
great movie good really not I know it
had a Marjoe Gortner it was in star
crash yeah wasn't he like okay
March Oh Courtney wasn't he like a no I
thought he was like an athlete and then
he turned like a evangelist was he like
a Christian evangelist I don't know I
thought it was the same do later I
thought it was the same dude from
greatest American William Katt yeah that
was a terrible series remember it really
was I mean all I remember is the theme
song I don't know if I ever really
Superman ripoff it was hilarious I don't
even remember what happened in that [ __ ]
like he was just like I think it didn't
last long did aliens like brinkema I
don't remember I don't remember I
remember being a kid seeing it you know
it was coming on being very disapoint
pointed with it yeah yeah wasn't
Superman not buy anything not buy any
it's not with that hair no I had a
couple of them around that time they
were tried to bring to the TV screen I
think they even had a Spider Man I think
they had a Captain America that didn't
last long
I'm cabinet yeah they didn't really get
its really they didn't they didn't get
superhero [ __ ] together until recently
you know what I mean
when I've actually made decent superhero
movies like because Hulk get credible
halt with Bill Bixby okay I love that
one that was like in the 70 here I
haven't seen it since I was a kid so I
don't know in those days I was cool it
was just little yeah alley tail since
[ __ ] Lou Lou Ferrigno bust out bust
out of his shoes [ __ ] [ __ ] up many calm
down I always thought his shoe budget
must have been like atrocious man well
you didn't notice that it was just the
same [ __ ] stock footage over and over
again yeah because all I could imagine
like all I could imagine was Bill
Bixby's closet at home and it just had
like the exact same pair of shoes it's
like he had like 500 don't like he
bought up in Vulcans like every time you
hold that I remember correctly the
transformation scene which was always at
night in the rain whether it was raining
or at night in the middle of the date
actually sometimes he would just go in
as Bill Bixby and then come out as like
in The Hulk if they didn't have the
names Fred is so much transformation so
his eyes show his eyes go white yeah
that was like TV man it's not like not
like nowadays where they have prestige
TV shows they gave him like one or two
million dollars in episode it had good
had good writing though and had a great
[ __ ] theme song at the end where he's
[ __ ] walking away [ __ ] all [ __ ]
broke dick Wow that's a you just that
you sucked with music I guess banner
could never get his life together he had
to move on he had to walk from one time
to the next
come on Kane come on Kane from kung fu'
big green just green one yeah but yeah
so if you have shudder like I said check
out mausoleum - it's not a great movie
and [ __ ] Marjoe Gortner was not the
best part of it but there was titties
and there was some gore and it was kind
of funny that the the main woman that
was in it she was having a Playboy bunny
or something like that I feel like I say
showed her tits a lot but um she like
turned into a demon or something she
invited a demon into her like in the
mausoleum or yeah something like that
yes and then
like speaking of Hulk she would like her
eyes would go green and she could do
like telekinesis telekinesis yeah Tipler
touch the green with me about the Hulk
being well written and everything got
other guys talking about them erasing
history yeah they got erased history
they're gonna try to erase history they
have to to have to erase history if not
then they wouldn't be able to [ __ ] do
it it is that they want to do it won't
learning it won't work though too many
people know desperate attempt that's all
this yeah desperate team can't you can't
[ __ ] erase history did somebody say
that somebody say mausoleum was built
accidents debut was it I don't think
that was he was the guy that was in
[ __ ] you know just me yeah and he was
a he's actor muscle oh that's a guy from
[ __ ] aliens alien yeah he directed
some if he did frailty member we
reviewed that yeah I don't think he did
this one though I can't remember the
name of the guy that else he was the one
word they thought they were killing
demons right yeah that was his best
movie he was [ __ ] great in that movie
yeah he directed more movies ya know
it's like there's a fundamentalist movie
and it turned out that they really were
seeing demons that's creepy [ __ ] yeah
yeah I remember that yeah yeah yeah we
repeat it yeah that's it that's a good
movie yeah yeah it's kind of an
underrated one yeah if you know what I
mean Christian [ __ ] movies have a
terrible reputation for [ __ ] quality
but that's the best one I think that
well yeah cuz every now and that well if
you make one that's not explicitly
that's still a good it just really does
seem like from all the stuff turns up on
because it because I really like that
podcast got awful movies and they have a
subscription to pure flicks which is
like the Christian Netflix like to get
movies yeah and it's like some of the
movies on there I can't even like
[ __ ] believe they gave digs in aid
yeah you know what I mean it's kind of
like you God didn't [ __ ] horror
movies at least those are fun yeah you
know what I mean they're also dialogue
heavy though what was the one that we
thought was I don't really go I was
turned into a crow yeah it's like what's
that Ugandan like you thought it was us
yeah somewhere you can watch them free
on Netflix or not YouTube free on
YouTube Ugandan [ __ ] horror movies
you gotta get gangster movie
and there they're like and in there
there's no sit length they're just as
long as they have to be some of them are
like I don't have a problem with
something or like hour and twenty
minutes some are like four hours long
and they're it's they're funny because
they're clearly made I mean whoever's
making it up as they go along well and
it's the same you know they used the
same program to make it yeah they made
as the dudes that made Birdemic
yeah it's like you can tell it's like
the same bird effect of the same
acceleration effect
yes actually though I gotta back off of
that because that Paxton movie wasn't
the best Christian movie was the best
Christian horror movie I think what
about the Exorcist stuff was that I
don't yeah I guess that'd be Christian I
mean you could consider at that because
that's kind of like who the heroes were
the best Christian movie was also a damn
Jewish movie knows Noah so that's Old
Testament yeah dad I like that one
Aronofsky wouldn't ya there yeah that
was a real good one I wish I wish I
cover of elation yeah I talked about
that yeah I think we've mentioned that
before I'd be awesome they've just be
like a [ __ ] acid trip pages scrolling
by and David should make that [ __ ] yeah
altered states movie with the puck yeah
Ram but the seven eyes and all that yes
that was directed that yeah Russell
still alive I don't even know quick
shout out for the love of my life Karen
black she's so rad I was just thinking
about that movie that she was in the
other day that burnt-offerings because I
think somebody oh we were watching that
thing on to be that fifty fifty greatest
horror movies you've met you've never
seen or something even though I had seen
probably like 95 percent of them but I
didn't get offended seeing what people
are talking about yeah do you want to
wrap it up since we're already because
it's short stream you guys got any
questions kind of thing you want to talk
about Ken Russell is dead yeah I figured
yeah we have to do we should do some
more of his movies cuz I really wanted
to do gothic and maybe the Devils but um
I don't know we'll get around and I even
like Larry the white worm I know that
one's kind of tense you know in a long
time reversal that's based on our Bram
Stoker novella tell you what that's
super weird yeah
Haitian movie what about the Voodoo that
was a lot better than I'm surfing the
rainbow that's Craven it was a lot
better now remember it yeah see I told
you yeah we should do like more cult
movies too because somebody asked me to
do the believers and that was another
one that I've been wanting to do I think
Martin Sheen was in that that came out
what 87 I feel like it was 87 cuz I
think I saw it in the theater but um I
you know I liked all those kind of like
weird cult movies about cults yesterday
so any questions or anything uh yeah
mega badger just said I seem to recall
the people attending church went up when
the extras came out yeah I do you feel
like but you know that that whole
stretch like Rosemary's Baby like
through the Exorcist and all the Satanic
movies of the 70s I think that was kind
of when because I feel like people it
started getting like less religious but
then when that happened it was kind of
like oh thank you thank you manga badger
very much for the drinks fund
yeah if you guys haven't seen them bill
paxton movie go check that out
you can either price there for free
probably good man um it might be on to
be it was like I I remember seeing it on
there like a few weeks ago but I don't
know if it's still there frailty frailty
yeah yeah yeah pretty cool have you guys
seen sorcerer the William Friedkin one I
don't think I've seen that but it's on
my list of like [ __ ] to watch now that
I'm like thinking about movies by big
directors that don't get loved that they
deserve if anybody has not seen it you
should could see sisters by Brian De
Palma I don't remember I really really
like that Margot Kidder was in it she
plays twins yeah before she got bombed
out when she was still young yeah yeah
this was like real it's it's from like
the early 70s it might be even before
Carrie came out Margot Kidder was cute
when she she was yeah but then she just
drank herself to pieces she was my
favorite character in black Christmas
yeah because she was like a foul-mouthed
I was funky chick and it was awesome
yeah the whole scene in the [ __ ] yeah
police thing with fellatio and all that
other kind of stuff all right so we're
gonna wrap up this little matinee review
hope you guys enjoyed it we'll probably
do another livestream maybe Saturday
might be you might be a movie review
might be a side tracks we'll see
whatever we end up watching so we'll see
you guys
next time see ya